bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
sur les 40 ans de saint quentin en
yvelines consacré à l'urbanisme alors
comment on a fait jaillir une ville de
terre comme on a créé un urbanisme est
ce que la ville nouvelle est aujourd'hui
achevée voilà quelques unes des
questions qu'ils ont abordé avec nos
invités avec jean-dominique de l'adieu
bonjour vous êtes historien du musée de
la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
michel devez vous êtes architecte
notamment l'architecte 17 mar
je travaillais quand l'architecte de ses
programmes éducatifs de la cour donc on
va en parler parce que c'est un quartier
fondateur évidemment il est également
architecte et vous êtes créateur des des
habitants autogéré de 2 millions pour
notamment j'ai réalisé quelques
opérations de d'architecturé autogéré et
je ne suis pas le seul donc deux
architectes modeste
c'est sympa ce qui existait et robert
cadalbert vous êtes donc le président de
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines leur
exploit de faire sortir comme ça il une
ville d'autun et ce qui s'est passé on
va raconter un petit peu cette histoire
c'est que on a commencé par la
périphérie plutôt par le centre ce sont
les premières années
hier soir et je vais peut-être en valais
avec plus élevé puisque vous étiez set
je crois que c'était votre premier
projet la sortie de l'école c'est vrai
qu'on a commencé à construire plutôt la
périphérique le centre de saint quentin
en yvelines contrairement à ce qui s'est
passé dans d'autres villes nouvelles
pourquoi on a fait on a opéré comme ça
au contraire de deux villes nouvelles
comme sergio on a commencé par le centre
préfecture le centre de saint quentin
était initiée au 117 enfin la ville de
saint quentin davies a été initié le
premier centre c'était le sens de cette
main je crois que fait d'abord je dois
préciser que j'étais architecte au
cabinet philippe et martin des langues
qui l'a les architectes en chef
et que vous très vite ils m'ont demandé
de les représenter sur saint quentin en
yvelines sorti de l'école de sorte à
l'école c'était un mois après mon même
pour un bijou après mon diplôme et donc
je suis arrivé là fais gaffe super
surtout pas de chômage a changé allegro
et surtout surtout c'était un bonheur je
travaillais avec philippe léventine des
hommes qui étaient des gens pleins
d'imagination plein de vie et qui en
plus mon complètement libéré de tous les
toutous les contraintes et les
contraintes le sérieux des écoles
d'architecturé
cette marre parce que la vie nouvelle et
est divisée au gré des communes y avait
onze communes à l'origine était divisé
aura des communes parle par des projets
de centres et donc pour
pour faire vivre ces centres il fallait
qu'il soit construit on
en ensemble quoi commerce le général en
activité hôtel de ville etc etc et donc
les 7 marc vous présentez un noyau qui
était pris entre maurepas et tout
l'ensemble des logements des nouveaux
horizons qu'ils sont
à l'opposé nous repas c'est dire que
déjà il y avait une présence assez forte
l'origine à ma connaissance et donc le
centre de cette mare été lancé comme ça
ça représentait une population à
l'origine je crois de 5000 habitants et
un centre commercial plus les
équipements nécessaires les cinémas le
rockstore etc fois ce qu'on appelait il
ya cette idée dès le départ et
au four de séparer un peu il ya de faire
une ville pour les piétons de faire ça
par strates avec qui sont dessous et
c'était aussi un peu d'inspiration de le
corbusier la charte d'athènes un qui fit
préconisé de d'avoir des espaces verts
libre d'implanter les bâtiments de
logements ou autres dans dans un parc
etc et c'est ce qui a été essayée au 7
mars si ce n'est que cette main il y
avait un centre il y avait enfin la
programmation d'un centre ville avec ses
commerces et avec tous ses équipements
le
comment le la fonction des deux se
sentent d'abord les ingénieurs des
voiries et autres qui sont intervenus en
premier temps et qui ont tracé des
grandes gloires et très large qui
séparait très largement tous tous les
quartiers ce qui fait que ses sentent
que 7 mars et sont devenus des cendres
très introverti mais qui fonctionnait
selon les principes selon les préceptes
de notre maître de la comédie le corps
buzet ya aussi un esprit
suffit de l'habitat autogéré oui alors
je voulais préciser malgré tout que
michèle v qui est décidément modeste a
également réalisé une opération
d'habitants autogéré une seule dans
laquelle il dans lequel ils habitent
voilà un alors oui effectivement il dit
d'un libraire voilà enfin des artistes
des architectes qui habite un drone
voilà ça c'est une bonne chose
qui leur est très l'obligation sas hotel
adéquat des grands ensembles si ces
habitats autogéré alors ses habitantes
ont géré c'est effectivement l'émanation
de ce post soixante huitarde et il ya eu
un mouvement qui c'est qui s'est créé
une association qui s'appelait le mhg à
le mouvement pour l'habitat groupé
autour j'irai qui fédérer un certain
nombre d'expériences une des premières a
eu lieu à meudon le me dont les jardins
et puisqu'elle saïsset mais un petit peu
c'était dans la cité dans l'air du temps
et
et ça correspondait notre génération 30
ans les soixante huitards avait 30 ans
henry a fait près même pas qu'il avait
fait d'ailleurs peuvent donc on partait
de zéro ex nihilo
c'est l'habitat où les gens se
regroupent spontanément par affinités
naturellement et essayer de bâtir en
commun un projet d'habitat il ya des
propriétaires il y avait on est plein
d'une façon générale c'est une s'est
tassé de l'accession mais avec des
variations de budget très grande une
grande hétérogénéité est la seule
communauté c'est la communauté d'esprit
et le l'objectif de vivre en du vivre
ensemble par contre on avait des niveaux
de revenus très hétérogène cela dit à
l'époque on était tous assez faucher
donc un des arguments étaient aussi
économiques c'est en se groupant on
arrivait à obtenir quelques coups
d'échelle intéressant mais le fond de la
faire c'était effectivement de monter un
groupement d'habitat qu'on se façonner
alors le moteur là dedans et évidemment
l'architecte quand ils y habitent la
plupart du temps il y habite certains
fois puisqu'on en a réalisé d'autres il
n'ya pas systématiquement un architecte
y en a souvent mais pas toujours et
voilà voilà le principe si vous voulez
alors on va parler après de la création
d'une sorte de 50 m avec coups
l'adieu mais justement je reviens au 7
mars est vrai que cette sorte de
protection est un moment devenu une
sorte aussi d'isolement et on a été
obligé de détruire la passerelle de
cette barre je propose regarder un sujet
qui revient sur cette destruction
elle faisait partie du décor 17 mar
depuis sa construction au début de la
ville nouvelle il y a 20 ans cette
semaine et à deux reprises elle a subi
l'assaut des grues et des marteaux
piqueurs pour un dernier baroud
d'honneur la vieille passerelle 17 mar
cordon ombilical entre le quartier de la
nouvelle amsterdam et le centre n'est
plus en jambes en pour la dernière fois
la venue du 19 mars 1962
cette vieille dame n'a pas eu d'épitaphe
si les habitants avaient dû l'écrire il
aurait pu s'intituler ni fleurs ni
couronnes et j'ai vu construire tout ça
avant ici tout ça c'était des champs
avec des vaches
et petit à petit j'ai vu construire ça
je pense que c'est là bas ça fait qu une
horreur ça aussi et justement je suis
très contente quand le charger commettre
quelque chose de mieux bah je trouve que
ce que ouais c'est pas une grande perte
quoi parce que le servait pas à grand
chose plus facile de passer par la route
il faut que renouvelle tous il
renouvelle les immeubles et tout ça elle
devra renouveler pour bien sur le
parking même ici devra être au fait je
trouve que c'est une bonne idée inscrit
dans le cadre du programme de
restructuration 17 mar la destruction de
cette passerelle marque la première
phase des travaux de réhabilitation
après viendra la création d'une place
triangulaire ouverte sur l'avenue du 19
mars et le déplacement de la station
service bp et de l'intermarché des
travaux d'infrastructures mais aussi de
construction puisque une série
d'immeubles est en train de sortir de
terre toujours sur cette même avenue la
fin des travaux est prévue pour 1994 les
élans courtois disposeront alors d'un
centre désenclaver et entièrement rénové
deuxième partie donc du rêve à la
réalité mais peut-être un mode de vie
s'élever sur cette disparition de la
passerelle 17 bat vous considérez que
c'est du bricolage
les passerelles décès par faisait partie
du maillage piétons séparer du maillage
automobile qui permettait de passer d'un
quartier à l'autre et c'est vrai la
réflexion qui a été fait tout allez ola
dans le
genre l'emprunter très peu y avec nos
enfants qui jouaient à bicyclette dessus
fois qu'il passait en bicyclette dessus
mais monfils est passé sur le parapet
dessus et cette passerelle en dans les
années 90 ont fait début des années 90 a
été plus ou moins embarquée par un
camion qui était trop
légèrement déplacé c'est comme a été peu
empruntés à la suite de cet accident il
s'est passé ça
par contre d'autres communications sont
restés c'est à dire entre les le 117 mas
et le centre des échoppes à maurepas
envers le centre de maurepas et une
autre communication est resté c'est un
tunnel sculptures que j'avais fait entre
le 7 mai et nouveaux horizons alors on
va arriver à la construction justement
du centre de 50 à
80 7 est ce que je veux faire vous
inscrire l'intervention de la politique
sur cette construction déjà par
définition à ce qui est normal
d'ailleurs déjà bien souvent je fais des
salaires l'urbanisme c'est un phénomène
politique et sens au sens classique du
mot politique dans la conduite des
affaires de la cité et en l'occurrence
en l'occurrence de l'agglomération ce
qui concerne le territoire en ce qui
concerne ses confères de 50 alors c'est
évident que
la construction du centre de saint
quentin en yvelines constitue d'abord un
grand tournant dans l'histoire du
territoire du tertiaire de saint quentin
et c'est également un événement
politique très fort parce que le projet
d'aménagement
de ce qui devait être ce qui était prévu
être le centre de 2,50
et qui avait été élaboré par
l'établissement public d'aménagement
a été
refusée par le syndicat intercommunal
qui évoque était le syndicat
communautaire d'aménagement dont qui est
l émanation l'émanation des communes et
a regroupé des représentants de magna
voilà qui va devenir le strip
voilà exactement il ya eu des tensions
comme ça entre les parce que c'est vrai
que les villes nouvelles au départ c'est
quand même une volonté de l'état
actuellement sur se sentent alors ça
arrive à un moment juste rap et 80
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe la décentralisation c'est vrai
même si on y revient dessus actuellement
malheureusement la décentralisation est
très très forte pour nous c'était pas
seulement des discours les lois de la
détresse était concrètement les élus
voulaient effectivement discuté avec les
habitants pour avoir un centre qui leur
conviennent et c'est pour ça que pour
nous un centre qui était avant tout un
centre commercial voire en voulait qui
est toute la mixité des fonctions du
commerce mais beaucoup de culture on a
mis la scène nationale on a mis de la
villa de l'habitat bien sûr de l'habitat
de la culture et de l'enseignement bien
sûr l'université qu'on a fait rentrer et
on voit bien on continue avec l'arrivée
de la fac de médecine dans le centre les
lycées lycées et cake est là et bien sûr
de l'activité pour ken vrai midi l'envi
que ça devienne un grand centre
commercial qu'on voit là en clair pour
nous le centre de la ville ne vais pas
être simplement le temple de la
consommation est le temple du savoir
vivre ensemble le slogan c'était pas de
cathédrale de la consommation à 50/50 et
en aiguille et l'exode polémique ah oui
il ya eu énormément énormément de il ya
eu énormément de polémique alors il faut
il faut se rappeler quand même c'est pas
la première fois qu'il ya un conflit
entre les aménageurs et les élus depuis
les débuts de saint quentin en yvelines
il ya eu quasiment toujours y avait dans
les mains que ça mais c'est celle là
c'est la première fois que que le que
les élus ont été en mesure
de dôme liger l'établissement public
d'aménagement à revoir complètement
complètement sa copie c'est en ce sens
c'est en ce sens que je disais tout à
l'heure
c'est un vrai tournant qu'à cergy ou qu
à evry aussi les mêmes conflits mais
c'est à dire que là on avait le centre
ville voilà faire alors que cergy
s'était agi c'était l'état au
département cergy
cergy evry qu'on le centre a été a été a
été construit c'était au tout début de
nouvelles donc il n'y avait pas encore
eu la réappropriation de l'urbanisme par
parra par les communes tout simplement
ce que les communes n'étaient pas
d'accord n'existait pas mais l'heure
n'est pas là alors que là pour des
raisons x y et z donc on n'aura pas le
temps d'aborder ici le centre ne s'est
pas fait tout de suite ça et donc quand
il s'est fait ce qu'on avait dit déjà
commencé par la périphérie les ja déjà
quand il s'est fait et où vous aviez
certaines communes qui commençait déjà à
avoir pris des habitants donc de la
force et qui pouvait être en mesure de
de faire entendre leur point de vue
beaucoup plus
alors pas tellement de lui en cours mais
j'en mets tout toutes les communes
comique lobby c'est vrai que si j'avais
pas lu et lolë 81 et la décentralisation
est ce qu'on leur ait fait certainement
pas l'état serait de 13 ans bien sûr
c'est la colonne turquie on avait un
objet majeur on voulait mettre l'humain
au coeur de la ville par ses fonctions
d'urbanisme en mélangeant tout ça est ce
arrivé en 80 et j'irai qu' on est les
enfants de changer la vie et sinon je
pense que on serait pas du tout dans
cette configuration alors avant
d'aborder la question de ce qui va se
passer maintenant l'un des derniers
quartiers à avoir une jour c'est la clé
saint-pierre et je vous propose de
revoir la construction de l'église de
l'acte et saint pierre la clé de saint
pierre aura son église la première
pierre a été posée vendredi 4 juin par
le maire d'elancourt jean michel
fourgous l'évêque de versailles
monseigneur thomas et le futur célébrant
le père la loue une construction qui
fait suite à la demande des habitants de
la clé de saint pierre les travaux
devraient s'achever pour pâques 2000 ils
sont évalués à environ 3 millions de
francs essentiellement financée par
l'association diocésaine de versailles
presque tous les ans nous inaugurerons
soit un agrandissement d'église dans des
villes nouvelles soit une construction à
partir d'un prêt ou d'un champ voilà et
c'est le signe d'ailleurs de
l'augmentation de la population dans les
yvelines
question quand même aux deux esthètes
que vous êtes ce qui est devenu saint
quentin c'est ce que vous espériez ou
est ce que il ya des choses qui vous ont
choqué ou vous avez voulu autrement non
enfin moi je ne sais pas je vis à
saint-quentin j'ai mon agence à saint
quentin je travaille en partie sur saint
quentin en partie sur d'autres villes
nouvelles enfin jusque très loin mais
non on y est bien moi j'étais heureux
d'arriver à saint quentin
on m'a fait une fois j'ai une remarque
comme ça dix ans que je trouvais que la
ville nous a laissé en général était
trop n'était pas assez dense que il n'y
avait pas de point fort dans la vie
nouvelle grossesse et ont jeté d'une
fois puis ça a été discuté longtemps
encore jean paul alduy il vu trop sale
époque enfin un
espèce de regrets dans ce sens là
maintenant
non j'ai pas de
senneville a besoin d'être prise c'est à
dire que ont fait les villes anciennes
était fait au moins sur trois siècles et
reprise sur trois siècles là mais elle
était construite sur trois siècles c'est
vrai ça voilà justement maintenant on
les construit sur 30 ans il ya des trucs
est ce qu'elle est achevée la ville
nouvelle manille une ville toujours ans
de vie d'après il a vu le gros a été
fait mais maintenant elle va muter et
évoluer comme un porc vivant que ce
qu'elle est quoi et c'est normal
regard faire moi je peux vous citer une
anecdote c'est qu'effectivement c'est un
domaine sur lequel j'agis pas mal je
travaille de façon beaucoup plus sur des
échelles plus petit que michèle v mais
il ya un phénomène s'est tous les gens
qui veulent agrandir et reconfigurer
leur propre habitat faute de mutation
possible d'ailleurs sur le territoire
donc il ya une forte tendance à
améliorer à créer des extensions de ces
maisons
sous dans la mesure où le les règles
d'urbanisme l'autorisent apparemment
maintenant ça se décoince un petit peu
parce que souvent des problèmes de
densité mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui
c'est la preuve qu'à mon avis sans bien
ils n'ont pas envie de déménager il ya
pour ma part j'habite près à deux
proches du centre avec un espace vert
avec l'université et j'avoue pour rien
au monde je quitterai ce cette ville
justement cette volonté d'abord ne pas
avoir de trop grands ensembles
d'immeubles à taille humaine plutôt et
puis de rapprocher au fond les légendes
leur travail qui est pas trop non plus
utilisation de la voiture notre ville ça
a bien marché ça lui organisé au service
de l'humain dans ces affaires là et donc
au service de la vie on parlait tout à
l'heure du centre-ville qui devait être
mixées mais c'est partout c'est une
question d'équilibré dans le fonctions
essentielles que celle logement et le
travail c'est bien pour ça qu'on a
commencé là dessus mais le la vide ne
s'arrête pas au logement au travail
heureusement c'est pour ça qu'on a mis
le paquet sur la culture de l'affairé
sur des équipements sur cette vie
associative très très riche et j'irai
que c'est aujourd'hui ce qui fait
l'attractivité de saint quentin en
yvelines ce qui me frappe aujourd'hui
c'est des grandes entreprises je peux
les domaines comme la sodexo com ou pas
la coff comme régis mêmes quoi eds au
bout de 40 ans normalement leur business
plan il les a menés à partir de 50 ans
ils sont restés parce que de leur part
car ado lankaran salariés sont bien
allés dans ta vie donc ici sont bien se
répand chef d'entreprise simon personnel
est bien c'est que les productifs il est
bien dans sa peau bien dans son
entreprise et c'est ça qui fait la force
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et c'est
pas un slogan c'est regarder la décision
des grands groupes à rester à
reconstruire sur place parce que au bout
de quarante ans on est obligé de refaire
de l'urbaniste en vertu et dans le
domaine économique mais les gens sont
appropriés le territoire et la force de
sa langue d'origine c'est cette
attractivité iem si je je je souligne
que équipements mais je vais à raison on
aurait bien voulu être plus dense avait
même poussé un gros mot de dire aux gens
plus denses c'est on veut de l'espace on
veut les r r on veut tous veulent une
réalité
j'avais deux grands chantiers qui sont
la gare dubai le vélodrome
oui je pourrais y rajouter la fac de
médecine a fallu trois façons les trois
grands chantiers si vous l'aimez puis
l'enfouissement d'un appel du satrape
d'accord c'est tout ça c'est l'équilibré
de développement économique
effectivement mais ostagar avoir la
garde la travaux un sport c'est la
guerre mais on parle aussi beaucoup
d'arrivées du métro métro automatique du
grand paris à saint quentin en yvelines
pour nous c'est aussi fondamentale
la gare avait soixante dix mille gens
qui passent tous les jours c'est le
deuxième ou troisième gare de l'île de
france pour nous c'était scandaleux dans
les cas on a récupéré il ya 10 ans
seulement ces gars que dix ans qu'on a
récupéré de l'établissement public
d'aménagement cet égard il a fallu faire
les études la concertation est
aujourd'hui les travaux sont en cours et
je pense que on aura une gare à la
hauteur de l'ambition de saint quentin
en yvelines le vélodrome ces chantiers
mais janot drôme qu'elle même quelques
polémiques mais c'est une chance pour
saint quentin en yvelines normalement on
sera à quatre mois de l'ouverture des
jeux olympiques à saint-quentin nuit
l'imaginé l'a bien l'effervescence
l'effervescence de dans cinquante années
missile a été le cas mais de paris 2012
qui était effectivement surtout pour la
population de saint quentin en yvelines
un grand événement un grand enthousiasme
une effervescence pour le faire restera
un élément majeur de paris 2012 c'est le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et pas simplement parole de gros mais
pour toute la vie associative le sport
de haut niveau la fédération française
de cyclisme et tout le développement
économique qui aura autour de ce bouton
de saut voilà vous parliez du super
métro parce que saint quentin en
yvelines c'est aussi le grand paris et
je vous propose de regarder un sujet sur
ce super métro qui va voir le jour
ce n'est finalement pas une mais bien
deux gars qui devrait voir le jour à
saint quentin d'ici 2023 la société du
grand paris vient de dévoiler le schéma
d'ensemble de la rocade autour de la
capitale un schéma sur lequel on
retrouve les gars de saint quentin
universités et saint quentin est qui
devrait accueillir un super métro
automatique reliant la communauté
d'agglomération à satory nanterre massy
et orly un soulagement pour
saint-quentin deuxième pôle économique
de l'ouest parisien après la défense fin
janvier au moment de l'accord entre
l'état et la région ile-de-france
l'agglomération et est la grande oubliée
du projet pour nous c'est quand même là
venez en les transports en commun
conditionne le développement de nos
territoires
aujourd'hui on souffre déjà d'un manque
de transports en commun et bien sûr avec
les développements de paris saclay cette
tour nous est indispensable d'avoir une
desserte d'un métro léger automatique
concernant les emplacements des deux
gares que les écologistes se rassurent
contrairement à ce qui a pu être annoncé
les étangs de la minière ne devrait pas
être menacée selon la société du grand
paris le rôle de la gare saint quentin
universités est justement de permettre
le contournement par l'ouest de la zone
protégée 50 ares est quant à elle sera
construite dans les environs du
technocentre renault à guyancourt côté
chiffres la liaison orly massy via
versailles et saint quentin mesure 37 km
compte onze gares et devrait coûter
environ 2,3 milliards d'euros
l'agglomération espère que la première
tranche saint-quentin massy sera terminé
pour la ryder cup 2018
robert cadalbert 50 ha c'est le grand
paris 7 les parties de grande-vallée
grand paris c'est d'abord un ensemble de
métropole qui doivent être structurées
équilibré et reliées entre elles et
qu'effectivement le transport en commun
est un élément majeur se trouvait à
quelques dizaines de minutes d'orly de
la défense de rejoindre le pôle cocu
représenter ficm ans mercy la gare tgv
de massy est fondamental pour l'avenir
des habitants et de nos entrepôts que
c'est aussi un grand paris pour 51 si
j'assume et un grand paris sans cesse
sans assommer 500s avec est évidemment
peut-être aussi des polémiques qui vont
voir le jour non avec
l'essai de construire justement voir
mais non mais les gars tous les projets
sont soumet à polémique après ces
conditions d' équilibre d'écouter les
arguments puisque tous les arguments
privé pris un événement sont recevables
entendable simplement l'intérêt général
c'est pas la somme de tous ces intérêts
particuliers et le rôle des élus comme
des décideurs à cette sphère
effectivement tranché décidé par rapport
à tous ces intérêts qui peuvent être
vraiment divergent sans nommer les
radios les l'historien que vous êtes ce
qu'ils voient comme ça poindre des
vestiges et je veux les jeux voir ce qui
est intéressant effectivement pour un
historien c'est de voir que on est à
peine sorti d'une opération d'intérêt
national la ville nouvelle que on rentre
dans une autre opération d'intérêt
national qui est le grand paris et
l'aménagement d'un plateau du plateau
paris saclay alors
c'est aussi quand on quand on regarde un
petit peu en arrière on se dit je crois
que c'est malraux qui disait l'histoire
ne se répète pas elle bégaie
et c'était c'était un petit peu ça parce
que dans les années au milieu des années
60 quand on a
organisé donc ce territoire il était à
l'origine à l'origine des aménageurs
travailler sur un périmètre d'étude qui
allait comme par hasard de de
pontchartrain
jusqu'à jusqu'à palaiseau et qui
inquiets qu'ils ont de l'eau mais le
plateau de saclay alors ce qui ne s'est
pas fait
dans ces années là pour des raisons oui
diverses et variées r c'est finalement
sarr vous à voir venez ça revient sur le
sur le sur le tapis je crois que c'est
l'histoire qui se venge finalement
effective et qui finalement revient
alors là revient à la charge et qui pose
qui pose tout un tas de paris s'en est
ce effectivement
et de dire et de défis qu'il va falloir
qu'il va falloir résoudre parce que
parce que il y en a pas le temps de
l'aborder là mais il ya tout un tas de
problèmes qui vont ceux qui vont ceux
qui vont se poser notamment le problème
de la répartition des logements etc etc
mais effectivement c'est une
séduire dans le formidable absolument il
va sacrer d'une chance de tout sens il
va falloir des problèmes c'est vrai
qu'il ya des prêts il était d'abord une
change et le champion de territoire pour
nos jeunes pendant travail commence
merci infiniment merci avec des mots
parfois on pourrait rester très
longtemps sans merci infiniment à tous
les quatre cette émission sur
l'urbanisme est terminé mais on se
retrouve très vite pour d'autres
émissions sur les 40 ans de saint
quentin en yvelines